okay right hey going I can see a few
graphs on yeah that's good all right and
most of yours look better than mine mine
is quite obviously bad but hopefully the
important part of it you can see let's
think back to this is weird sorry I feel
weird with this thing I'm feeling anyway
if you remember back to when we look at
you know functions relations and inverse
functions right one of the important
zippers we looked at was x squared and
we said you're going to turn this
function and gets inverse right if you
just reversed your inputs and outputs
right and you just went x equals y
squared you won't get an inverse
function do you mean but what we would
get instead yeah that's right because
it's gonna it'll fail the vertical line
test
yes so therefore what we did was we
restricted the domain we just took this
part here where execrate that different
zero and when you took the universe with
that and what you ended up with was a
function and we're all happy okay so it
was this restriction of domain that was
the important idea
some people argue that with voices that
carry anyway you can see we're gonna
have the same issue here with Y cosine X
and cos and tan because their periodic
right
so being that if you think about this
way the a parabola y equals x squared
right
it fails the it fails the horizontal
line test right so when you turn it over
it fails the vertical line test okay so
because all three functions are periodic
they're all going to fail the horizontal
- B time okay so the question is where
should we restrict the domain now get
yourself out another color if you've got
one and you can see more than y equals a
square will be more or less just had two
choices okay here we've got a set of
choices okay
now do you remember I sort of I made a
big deal of the fact that the point
where you can choose which way to go
right the point was the turning point
you can go to the left of the turning
point or to the right of the turning
point so every time you have a turning
point here that gives us a new domain
within which we can restrict sine ends
okay I probably should have labeled them
this is sine X right if I start all the
way from the left hand side from these
two points less you to this turn you're
fine okay
if I take this section it'll pass the
horizontal line test so when I turn over
it'll pass the vertical line test okay
now what is this
yeah cuz it's two and a half yep good
that's fine if I go over a little more
again between these two twin points I've
got another choice right I could go from
minus five point two two - so each time
I've got a PI radians that's my space
yeah I can go from here yeah okay and
now I've gotten to this section which
has the origin in it okay so this
section in the middle here which is -
pound - to be positive plan - okay
obviously I mean we've done all the work
if I were to keep on going in the right
hand side
it'd just be all the same numbers but
positive okay so just like we did y
equals x squared right and we chose this
positive side because it seemed to make
sense for the kinds of applications that
we will use it for right the most
sensible place to restrict the domain is
in the middle now can anyone tell me
apart from the fact that you know we
don't like big numbers what actual
reasons might we be interested in
keeping it within this range okay let's
let's pedal back a couple of steps -
that's true so if I use if I if I take
this term and dubstep function if I take
this domain right I'm actually gonna get
acute angles out of it right anyway you
go outside of that whether you go
through the left or to the right
you're either obtuse or reflux or bigger
and bigger and bigger
okay so if I'm gonna use the inverse of
this Y cosine inverse of X if I'm going
to use it for measurement in triangles
then it makes sense if you could domain
with the key angles in it alright so joy
yourself a new set of axes underneath
and we're going to draw the inverse
where we're going to note down a few
important geometric properties about it
okay so I do new set of axes just draw
in the section of Y cosine X that we're
going to choose okay
so should that - final - okay so now by
the way for this when you draw in y
equals sine X we're going to superimpose
sine inverse X on top of it and it's
gonna be easy to confuse them okay so
either if you don't have another color
throw this in mcdonnen minds I know
usually we say dotted lines are
asymptotes that's good thing but we need
to distinguish between these somehow
otherwise you do they're very they're
very very similar but I've got more
color so I'm going to use it okay now
there were from minus PI to 2 plan - now
do you remember in order to get from a
function to its inverse
you can reflect it across a certain line
right what was the line again why cause
that's good now where is y equals x on
this graph now if you remember when we
were doing when we were going back to
young when we first arrived the results
for the derivatives of all the trig
functions okay
one of the results we had to prove was
that sine x x + 10 x right they all
approach the same values for small
values of x do you remember that we use
Radian measure to show that so therefore
what are you going to get all of these
are tangent to each other at the origin
okay so here's what I'm gonna draw here
y cos x ought to look like this
okay
so if you want to think about it this
way it goes just above sine X and just
below 10 X if I were to draw that in as
well which I'm not confusing enough
around okay now what happens when I
reflective what happens when I reflect
it so it may help you to turn your head
just a little bit okay and I want to get
this symmetry happening yeah so this now
you can do in whatever color is your
main color this is the kind of shape
okay sir have a look at with me now it's
a bit tricky I think we have done the
scale a little bit because you know this
is actually strictly speaking this ought
to be 45 degrees if it was one-to-one
while it's not important things to note
down and I would actually I would
actually suggest you to write some of
these things now for starters this is y
equals sine inverse of X right it's not
the same as x equals sine Y it's not the
same as x equals sine way because if I
just swapped the X's and Y's just like
with y equals x squared and x equals y
squared what do I get I don't get near
this function I get up okay so I should
say Y cosine inverse of X is not equal
okay so the first thing that is this is
an inverse function from a restricted
domain
and the the restricted domain obviously
it implies a restricted range as well
okay where is this this is an inverse
relation because it doesn't have a UH a
restrictive domain on it right if I were
to draw the whole thing I want to look
like it looks like this and we're just
going forever never never right fails
the vertical line test that's why it's a
relationship okay so there's the first
thing to note the second thing to see
about its shape right is that because
I've switched X's and Y's okay things
that used to be horizontal I'm now going
to be vertical right so remember use
them usually at this point right I have
our stationary point there yeah so if I
were to draw a tangent in it would be
horizontal here and it should be far as
local here as well okay so since I've
swapped everything right now here I
should have vertical sort of tangents
right if I don't draw something in that
line there it should be vertical okay so
just as Y cosine X has horizontal
tangents at its endpoints
namely ponzu and okay in exactly the
same way I'm gonna have vertical
tangents at the endpoints here now again
I've swapped X's and Y's right so x
equals with my spine two enemies it was
planning to I'm not going to be my
endpoints anymore what are they remember
excellent why that's right so so I'm
going from my Y range used to be minus 1
to 1 okay so now for my inverse function
my domain will also be minus 1 to 1 okay
so my endpoints are going to be like Y
so just as this has horizontal tangents
this will have vertical tangents and
it's end points respectively different
okay all right what else do we want to
note oh yeah I want to add one more
thing which is that sine inverse of X
right because I flipped it across y
equals x and the original graph was
tangent to y equals x the new graph
should also be tangent to wife is X
right so it's going to a 45-degree angle
if you do it one to one I'll add the
origin
okay happy right so there are some
geometric features about signing us
today's let's rehearse the same kind of
process but let's do it for cosine now
what make you draw quite as many repeats
for cosine as we did for sine but I
still want to do a couple so you can see
again we have to make a choice right so
now again I want to think about what
domains make sense to cut these you know
cut it into pieces so I get into this
function okay so again you go these
negative ones that are probably we've
already worked out you know that's not
very helpful
between this stationary point and this
stationary point would be much like you
know doing y equals minus root X the
exquisite why would you do that why
would you take negative angles when you
don't have to okay so therefore the next
domain that makes sense is here right
from 0 to PI radians okay now here's the
important thing to yet why are we
restricted restricting it in this way
why are we arbitrarily picked a
different domain to restrict crochet as
compared to side
that's right if we pits because I always
thought this is frustrating
nothing she's just want to make life
hard for us right today like I'm just
gonna pick random different domains so
you have more things to memorize but the
reason why did I pick the same domain is
because it wouldn't work because it
would fail the horizontal line test so
when you turn it over it'll fail the
vertical line test so you won't get a
function okay right sir
what is it going to look like if I do
off from 0 K now when we drew like was
sine inverse of X okay we had to go
positive negative because what we took
was positive but here all of these
angles are positive okay 0 to PI none of
them are over here okay so therefore
when I turn this over just like I have
all positive x values here the inverse
is going to have all positive why don't
does that make sense so when you draw
closed inverse we don't need one path ok
now he's a quick question for you
I don't you shouted out again I want you
to think it in your head and see if you
can look in right I have a choice now if
I'm going to turn this around
okay switch to the X's and Y's is it
gonna look like this or is it going to
look like this no throw it shout it out
just think about it is it is it
decreasing or is it increasing
now I just want you to submit in your
mind which one does it look like to you
okay you liked it in run it down write
down on the top of your page whether you
think it's decreasing or increasing just
so you know you come here and then your
friend can look at you saying are you
were wrong or I can find you're right
I'll admit okay because otherwise you
can say yeah you know I totally thought
it was absolutely right so write it down
write it down okay now keys there's a
couple of different ways to think about
these the first way that I think about
it is what does sine inverse look like
what did sign you know stuff like we
flipped it and it wasn't that hard right
it looked like this okay
so sine inverse is increasing okay now
what that corresponds to is the original
sign in that domain whose also
increasing yes
so increasing increasing now have a look
at the part of true sign the section
that we brushing to the donating right
clearly it's decreasing right so the way
I tend to think about it is since what
you start with is decreasing your
inverse is also going to be decreasing
okay you're gonna write alright it's
fine I frequently get it wrong which is
why I'm making a play to emphasize this
okay
the other way you can think about it is
just go through the toilets okay so for
instance have a look at this one okay
the Cartesian coordinates for this at
the moment are 0 1 right 0 1 so when I
swap them around it's going to be 1 0
right 1 0 swapped ok I just did x and y
in the same way if you have a look over
here the Cartesian coordinates to this
our PI minus one right up going down
okay
so therefore when I switch them around
I'm going to minus 1 pi and that looks
pretty decreasing to me okay now just
like with sine
we went from horizontal tangents at the
ends right to vertical tangents and you
get exactly the same thing here so in
fact it's the same shape but just like
sine and cosine are basically the change
to the same shape but they've been moved
that kind of thing okay so make sure
your vertical at these points just like
before you kind of want you kind of want
that angle to be about 45 degrees it
should be tangent to well it's not like
was X at that point is it what would it
be what is the tangent so that's that's
the okay right now by the way since this
guy is sort of floating off in the air
you have a choice you can either label
its coordinate like that most people
don't tend to do more common is to see a
PI up here okay but you have to define
it somehow it can't just be floating off
in the middle of nowhere without any
ribbon as to where it is okay I suppose
you could do both but I don't know why
you would because one is surface all
right now I've done sine and I've done
cosine for you it's your turn to do tan
okay so I want you to draw the original
version of tan just like we've been
doing with the other two functions and
then you make a choice what would tan
inverse look like okay and then we'll
draw a table and we'll make a summary of
everything